[Musique]
et décidément cette campagne
présidentielle est un rebondissement
hier l'écologiste yannick jadot a
rejoint benoit hamon après avoir trouvé
un accord avec le candidat ps et sur
france 2 il appelé jean luc mélenchon à
faire de même le candidat de la france
insoumise se dit lui ouvert à la
discussion julien gasparotto alexis
delcourt
yannick jadot est un homme pressé le
leader d'europe écologie les verts n'a
pas attendu le vote de ses militants
pour se rallier à benoît hamon dans les
rangs du parti la colère monte mais
yannick jadot est déjà dans le coup
d'après sitôt redirai il demande à jean
luc mélenchon de faire de même
pour la première fois l'écologie le
social l'europe et la démocratie peut
gagner une élection présidentielle alors
jean-luc parlons nous continuons à
travailler et créons cette grande
espérance autour d'un rassemblement
c'est pas facile je peux te le dire pour
moi ça n'est pas facile et bien mais
faisons le ensemble jean luc mélenchon
entend l'appel il répond quelques
minutes plus tard sur un autre plateau
et lance une invitation à benoît hamon
je suis d'accord dimanche ou lundi s'il
le veut pour le rencontrer je ne ferme
aucune porte
ce n'est pas moi qui ferme les portes je
suis prêt à dinard débattre at il dit je
te propose de principe d'une candidature
unique
je regarderai ce qu'ils me proposent ce
n'est pas ce qu'il fait madame salamé
mais je le regarderai quand même au même
moment benoît hamon lui est en meeting à
arras cela fait des semaines que les
deux hommes se renvoient la balle dans
son discours le candidat socialiste
appelle lui aussi au rassemblement mais
sans jamais citer jean luc mélenchon je
serai le travailleur inlassable
l'architecte inlassable l' artisan
inlassable jusqu'au bout du
rassemblement de la gauche dans cette
élection présidentielle je veut unir les
forces de gauche enso ne font pas que
des appareils et avec l'unité vous le
verrez nous raterons et avec l'unité
nous serons un rapide ce matin benoît
hamon a finalement accepté l'invitation
de jean-luc mélenchon cette rencontre
sera sans doute la dernière chance pour
les deux hommes de sceller une union
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]